[Music]
[Applause]
americans drink a lot of beer in fact
it's the number one drink of choice for
those who decide to imbibe totaling
about 26 gallons of beer for each
drinking age adult in 2020 but thanks to
climate change our future beers may be a
lot more expensive and not quite so
tasty senior national and environmental
correspondent ben tracy shows us why
the new belgium brewery in fort collins
colorado i love these guys is famous for
its fat tire ale and sizable supply of
suds now i'm big into pale ales i'm
drinking a sour right now but recently
ceo steve fetchheimer decided to craft a
new brew did you ever think you would
purposefully brew a horrible tasting
beer
it's not usually good business to make a
bad product
that left his brew master dave glor a
bit dazed and yes i was confused because
i'm not usually asked to make bad
tasting beers
it's called torched earth a beer that
would benefit from its own chaser it
tastes very burnt but i would almost say
band-aid if i had one word candy for
what it tastes like days like eating a
band-aid oh you're really selling this
and that's okay because new belgium
doesn't really want you to buy it it
wants you to learn something from it
what is the future of beer if we don't
really address climate change i think
beer is going to not only become very
expensive but is not going to be the
same quality of beer that people get to
enjoy today and so when we say expensive
what's a future six-pack if climate
change runs rampant we've talked about
a six-pack of fat tire costing a hundred
dollars
the three main ingredients in beer are
clean water barley and hops all are
threatened by climate change weather
extremes such as drought and flooding
are ravaging crops across the country
and this is the main source of new
belgium's water the pooder river just
outside fort collins historic wildfires
fueled by climate change
have burned the forest in the canyon and
polluted the river with ash and runoff
making the water supply at times
unusable
we view climate change as an existential
threat to new belgium so torched earth
is a wake-up call for consumers instead
of clean water it is brewed with the
smoke-tainted version high-quality hops
are replaced with climate-resilient
dandelion root and barley gets swapped
for buckwheat what is it like to look
forward and know that some of your
essential ingredients either may not be
available or are going to be a lot worse
than they are today it's a window into
how terrible things are at a somewhat
selfish
level you know that might be the least
of our worries
new belgium is aware that beer pales in
comparison to the deadly impacts of
climate change already impacting the
planet the brewery is trying to do its
part by powering much of its operation
with these solar panels katie wallace
new belgium's director of environmental
impact says torched earth is meant to
start a conversation some people could
look at this and say this is a bit of a
pr stunt what do you say to that if
climate change is our client then yes
it's a pr stunt for climate change and
the goal of that is to raise awareness
for climate action so i guess the
obligatory correspondent has to try the
bad beer
moment proper glassware i appreciate
that you're welcome
cheers cheers
here's mother earth all right
yeah
that's rough
it's bitter
yeah it's not good
dave glor who yes is the younger brother
of that other galore says torched earth
is not meant to be putrid but simply
probable it was an exercise in exploring
the way we might have to make beer not
how we want to make beer so is this the
beer you'd send your brother
most definitely i want him to always be
learning
learning that if we don't combat climate
change happy hour could become something
considerably more dour
for cbs saturday morning ben tracy fort
collins colorado
oh
i'm sorry brother it's nice that he
picks on you too i like that he does
well i mean i pick on him too
so um so ben had to take we we have to
taste bad yeah
yeah the obligatory tasting yes let's
learn to the glores to learn something
on this
i like it
it's i think it's
a bit of a it has a bitterness
not as bad as i was expecting so you
know trash
and it's still a can but um yeah that's
that's not the beer i want and i don't
want it to be more expensive if that's
it's not that bad guys really
we're trying to convince people that oh
i'm just kidding
it's not i mean you think about it
though with climate change if this is
what you're getting this beer for more
money that's not what you want that's
their point
i do like that when they ask about pr
and uh whether it's a pr stunts right
right and yeah and and she says if our
clients mother earth then yeah fine
right michelle's okay with it though
it's not that i'm emotional michelle's
gonna be pounding it's just that this is
probably what we're gonna be left with
if we don't get our act together how
about that
i like that there you go there it is